i've got a symbol today i'll make one
app okay so i've got uh i wanted to talk
about heisenberg's microscope which
comes back to the heisenberg uncertainty
principle which we've talked about in
various contexts
but this is a slightly different take on
it i need to give the brief summary as
to what we have talked about about
heisenberg's uncertainty principle just
to explain why what i'm going to say is
different the version of heisenberg's
uncertainty principle is basically this
this thing about the fact that you can't
measure the position and the momentum of
the particle at the same time so you
can't measure where it is and how fast
it's going both at the same time and
this is you know this is a very well
documented phenomenon in quantum
mechanics we know that it's true it's
sort of unavoidable because it actually
follows from a mathematic it follows
from the mathematics it's follows from a
mathematical technique called fourier
analysis we know that momentum is
associated with the wavelength of a wave
okay and so when you've got a particle
with a particular momentum that means
it's a wave which has you know a very
particular wavelength to it
and the only way you can have a wave
with a very specific wavelength is if it
goes on and on forever so that's a
particle which has incredibly
well-defined momentum because it's got a
wave that goes on forever so we know
exactly what its wavelength is but we
don't have a clue where it is because
the wave just goes on and on forever
so the way you can make
something more localized is what you
actually want is something like this
it's still a wave but it's kind of more
localized right it's a little bit of a
wave but it's all within some little
distance delta x
but what this technique of fourier
analysis tells you is that actually to
make a wavelength looks like that you
have to add a whole bunch of sine waves
together
like the way you make something that
looks like this is by adding waves of
slightly different wavelengths and in
the middle here they all interfere with
each other in a constructive way so they
all add up together but when you get out
here everything's interfering with
everything else and you end up with
nothing left over so the way you make
one of these little wave packets where
you've got the wave kind of restricted
in space is by adding a range of waves
together but of course each of these
waves has a slightly different
wavelength which means they have a
slightly different momentum associated
with it so now although we've made the
particle nicely localized in space it no
longer has a well-defined momentum it
can only you know it's we know it has a
momentum that's somewhere in the
associated with the range of this
wavelength the thing about this is it
doesn't actually although it looks like
you know there's kind of a wavelength
associated with this is because it's not
a nice neat sine wave anymore it doesn't
actually have a single well-defined
wavelength and in fact the only way you
can define the wavelength in this is in
terms of the wavelength of all its
constituent parts so that's why it
doesn't have a well-defined wavelength
so it doesn't have a well-defined
momentum and the more we squash this
thing up
to make the position well defined the
wider the range of wavelengths we have
to need to add together to make that
squash thing so the more uncertain the
momentum becomes so that is the
heisenberg uncertainty relationship that
says that the better you measure the
position of something the less well you
know its momentum or the better you
define the position of something the
less well you know it's momentum that's
where we were
the classic question that gets asked in
the comments sections of youtube videos
amongst other places is why don't we
just do the job really carefully right
if we just got a particle why don't we
just measure its position and momentum
really carefully and then we'll know
exactly where it is and we'll know what
its momentum is right we can measure its
momentum so none of this messing around
with adding waves together let's just do
the experiment as carefully as we can
and actually measure the position and
momentum of a particle so heisenberg set
up this thought experiment called which
is now generally called the heisenberg
microscope where he thought about what's
the carefulest way that we can measure
the position and momentum of a particle
so that's what he did what particle are
we talking about here it can be any i
mean he i think he thought about it in
terms of an electron but it could be any
particle you want it really is it's
because it's a very general experiment
right basically all he did is he said
here's my particle and i'm just going to
look at it and i'm going to look at it
with a microscope so i'm going to point
a lens at it i said because all the
microscope is in crude terms it's just a
lens okay and then i'm gonna have just a
single photon of light come along
bounce off that particle and end up
going into my microscope okay and then
i'm gonna make a picture that's just
this single photon because that's you
know i wanna do this as gently as i can
so i don't to be bombarding my particle
with lots of light i just want to touch
it as gently as i can with a single
photon so you take a picture of these
things now one of the things another
thing we've actually made videos about
in the past is this this effect called
diffraction
that says that actually if you've got a
lens or a mirror of finite size you
don't end up with a perfectly pin sharp
image you end up with the image slightly
blurred out through these effects of
diffraction and it's why you know a
strong one of the reasons why
astronomers like building bigger and
bigger telescopes is because the
diffraction limit gets smaller and
smaller the images get sharper which
means that if we were to look at our
particle with lots of light we wouldn't
see it as a single point right we'd
actually see it blurred out a bit just
from these effects of diffraction
even with one photon well if we've only
got one photon it's even worse than that
right because this is just saying that
actually if we make this image here with
lots of photons we'll see it blurred out
like that if we only see use one photon
it could be a photon that arrived here
or in the middle here or over here so
actually there'll be an uncertainty in
the position just associated with the
fact that we're only detecting one
photon
and so there's a fundamental
limitation
as to how well we can measure the
position of our particle that's just due
to these diffraction effects that the
fact that you've just got a rubbish lens
okay so let's fix the lens
so then that the and we can do that
right because we know that the formula
for diffraction says that the amount
this thing's blurred out by let's call
it delta theta is something like the
wavelength of the light you're using
divided by the diameter of the lens
okay so there's two ways we can make
delta theta smaller make our images
sharper either we can use a shorter
wavelength of light make the lambda
smaller or we can make the lens bigger
the diameter bigger and indeed we can do
that and we can make our images sharper
and sharper just by making the lens
bigger and bigger or using shorter and
shorter wavelengths of light however
that creates a problem of its own
because let's go back to our picture
we've got our particle here light
arriving and what's going to happen is
that light is going to bounce off the
particle and head off in some other
direction
and just by conservation of momentum if
the photon has gone kicked off that way
they're just like billiard balls
bouncing off each other if one ball goes
off that way this ball is going to
recoil in this direction and similarly
if it happened to have bounced off in
this direction
it would have recoiled in that direction
now if we make the lens bigger we've got
a whacking great lens here then actually
photons going in a very wide range of
possible directions
will all end up going through the lens
because we've made the lens bigger so
it's going to capture them and because
of these these photons are now heading
off in extreme directions that means
that there's they've kind of bounced
harder off the particle here so it's
going to get a bigger kick in that
direction
so there's now a bigger range of photon
directions that are going to get caught
by the lens to make a nice sharp image
but because there's a bigger range of
photon directions that means there's a
bigger uncertainty because we don't know
which direction the photon went in
therefore we don't know what direction
the the electron got kicked in and we
don't know how hard it got kicked and so
there's a bigger uncertainty in the
momentum of that particle
so that doesn't you know so that sort of
that doesn't help us in that we get a or
at least that sort of illustrates the
problem that we can make the image
sharper and sharper but by making the
position known better and better by
saying i've got a really detailed
picture and it's just there
um suddenly the uncertainty and the
momentum of the particle gets gets
larger and and so the then the other
thing we can do remember is we can
change the wavelength of the photon and
if we change the wavelength of the
photon that's going to make the image
sharper but of course the wavelength of
a photon is associated with its momentum
and if we make the wavelength shorter
that makes the momentum of the photon
bigger which means it gives the electron
a bigger kick as it goes past so that
also means that it gets kicked off in
some arbitrary direction by a larger
amount
and there is no way around this
trade-off between the two right if you
optimize your microscope more and more
for making the images sharper and
sharper you'll give the the particle
that's being imaged a bigger and bigger
kick in some random direction and really
not know where it's going
and that's so that's the essence of this
well it's a very elegant sort of it's a
thought experiment the heisenberg did
are saying you know am i just being
stupid here is there some clever way i
could actually measure both the position
and momentum of the particle at the same
time and it turns out you can't
well
why not
come up with a solution that doesn't
involve smashing it with a photon and
use it or using a lens come up with a
new way
that's that's my problem i just think i
think you're using a blunt instrument
you know a microscope is but how much
how much you know how much subtle can
you get i'm just using a single photon
of light i'm it's the minimum
disturbance i can possibly do to this
electron it's just illustr it's just
illuminating it with a single photon
anything else i can do is going to be
worse than that right i've got to
illuminate it with something because
i've got to see it to know where it is
so how am i going to know where it is if
i don't see it you know your son's at
school at the moment even though you
can't see him for example like there are
there are other
pieces of evidence you can use to know
information why do you have to why do
you have to see it to believe it can't
we come up with a new way to figure out
what our particles are doing you've got
to measure it right you really got to
measure it you can't just go on faith
that you know the particle's there
you've actually got to measure it to
measure it you have to interact with it
in some way just just to ask it are you
there you know and so actually this is
the subtlest way you can think of of
interacting with the particle to find
out whether it's so it's the subtlest
way heisenberg could think of okay so it
turns out so it turns out you touch on
an interesting point here because this
was so heisenberg came up with this
thing in 1927 right people are still
arguing about whether it's right or not
people came up with his way of actually
trying to do this kind of experiment and
a couple of years ago came up with a
result which seemed to do better
than the heisenberg relationship said
you could do